are you very aware that you try to
preserve fleeting moments well depends
what you call fleeting sometimes in the
geologic sense a year is a very freely
moment and sometime with the people is a
25th for a second these days you're most
likely to see the work of American
photographer Ansel Adams on a postcard
or on the wall of your boss's office
these photographs are so ubiquitous now
that it's easy to walk by them without
noticing their technical and aesthetic
mastery indeed thanks to things like
Instagram and snapchat photographs in
general are so ever-present in our lives
that standards about what we believe to
be great work in this field are drowned
out by the literally billions of photos
that are uploaded to these services
every day I come across something that
excites me I see the picture in my
mind's eye and I make the photograph and
then I give it to you as the equivalent
of what I saw and felt in the beginning
Ansel Adams took photographs not unlike
all those millions of us on Instagram as
a visual diary of his experience Adams
took his first brownie box camera on
trips to the Sierra Nevada mountains the
place that would enthrall him for the
rest of his life his early photographs
are enthusiastic but uninspired Adams
had that feeling that I have every
single time I pick up a still camera of
not getting in the print what I see with
my eyes now this is largely because the
dynamic range of the human eye the
brightest and darkest thing you can see
at the same time exceeds any film or
digital camera especially those Ansel
was using in the early 20th century but
this all changed for Adams on April 10th
1927 the footage you're watching right
now is from an excursion Adams took with
his future wife Virginia to the Half
Dome in Yosemite National Park hauling
his corona view camera two lenses two
filters a heavy wooden tripod and 12
glass plates he made his way onto the so
called diving board where you can look
along the side
of the massive granite dome and here
Adams had a vision of what he wanted his
image to look like he cites this as his
first conscious use of the technique
called visualization hokey lies lies
specifically in seeing into the mind's
eye which we call visualization first
Adams tried his yellow filter this is
the image it produced similar probably
to what Adam saw looking through the
camera's viewfinder but it's not what he
visualized in his mind's eye there was
no excitement in the frame so he took
out his red filter for a second shot he
set the exposure at f-22 and exposed the
plate for five seconds when Adams
developed this photo and it matched his
internal visualization he knew that this
was his life's calling and look at the
difference it makes the darkened sky
charges the image with drama and
intensity in contrast Adams had an
instinctive genius about tonal balance
and contrast and to formalize his craft
to ensure that he could achieve his
visualizations he developed another tool
with his friend Fred Archer called the
zone system the zone system splits the
full range of black to white into 11
separate zones each one f-stop or
aperture setting apart the
photographer's spot meters different
elements in his frame and determines
where everything fits in the zones this
way the photographer has a sense of what
his entire frame will look like before
he shoots knowing how everything will
change with different exposures but take
a look at Adams famous photo of the
Titans and the Snake River taken in 1942
the contrast here is really incredible
they get a better sense of it let's
pixelate the image look how Adams
represents basically every Zone in the
system all the way from zone 0 full
black in the shadow of the mountains
here to zone 10 in the light reflecting
off the river what's even more
extraordinary is his ability to capture
the highlight detail in the clouds and
elsewhere in the river and the shadow
details in the trees that cover the bank
perhaps
music is the most expressive of the arts
however as a photographer I believe that
creative photography when practiced in
terms of its inherent qualities may also
reveal endless horizons of meaning Ansel
Adams work his devotion to craft and
more importantly intention in
photography there's an important example
in our time when there are more pictures
posted in six months than there are
stars in the Milky Way galaxy
having fought so hard for the acceptance
of photography as an art Adams probably
would have laughed at a statistic like
that today everyone has a camera but how
many visualize what they're going to
capture beforehand how many measure the
light or hiked for a day to reach the
perfect spot so the next time you walk
by one of Ansel Adams photographs in the
hallway of your doctor's office take a
longer look and remember that our
photographic world is the one he gave us
the thing that excites me is if it in
love too many years we're going to have
a tile a new medium of expression at the
electronic image and I know the
potentials are there though it's going
to be wonderful
hey everybody thanks for watching I love
Ansel Adams such a good-hearted person
and a great artist and I had so much fun
making this a lot of cool things that I
was experimenting with here which is
what I love to do I just love to
experiment with editing and try to give
you something that I hope you haven't
seen before on youtube so if you wanna
help support this channel you can go
right here and go to my patreon page
pledge a dollar or three dollars per
video everything helps you guys have
been amazing and I will see you guys
next Wednesday for something new I'm
excited